hey guys i'm lisa foiles welcome to
analog isn't it funny how games try so
desperately hard to be dark and gritty
and post-apocalyptic and then everyone
just goes out and buys mario kart anyway
well it's easy to see why mario kart has
been consistently good for over 20 years
and the latest installment for the wii u
mario kart 8 made dare i say be the best
in the series but if you've driven this
game into the ground and need a new
karting experience or maybe one for a
different console then tap the brakes
here are three games like mario kart 8
everyone loves mario kart but there's
one downside it's on Nintendo systems
only luckily for 360 and ps3 owners
Sonic & all-stars racing transformed is
basically a Mario Kart clone just like
battle royale was a copycat of Smash
Brothers Sonic & all-stars racing
transformed despite having the worst
title is a tight racer with drifting
boosting weapons to screw up your
opponent's epic tracks everything you
know from Mario Kart instead of Nintendo
characters this is all sony and sega
it's a total nostalgia trip as you
navigate characters like ooh la la from
space channel 5 through tracks themed
like jet set radio and skies of arcadia
i'm a dreamcast fan the tracks are just
as topsy-turvy and colorfully chaotic as
mario kart including utilizing sonic
levels because that's a total no-brainer
the races aren't just on land either
your transform evolved iya khals become
boats for water portions and planes for
aerial maneuvering so you can dip dive
and barrel roll there's multiplayer
co-op items that rip off the blue shell
yeah this is mario kart except for
Danica Patrick being a playable
character peach would have none of that
you may remember modnation racers for
the ps3 but there was something missing
we didn't care about the characters the
way we care about Yoshi tails and now
Sackboy I'm talking about
littlebigplanet karting instead of the
shiny bigger-than-life courses in Mario
Kart littlebigplanet karting Strax make
you feel like you've been shrunk down
into an arts and crafts project with
cardboard cutouts stickers and sushi
rolls instead of tires it's a stupidly
adorable coat of paint on a kart racer
it still features all the mechanics
you're used to plus some grappling hook
action for Indiana jonesing / pits just
like littlebigplanet creativity is what
really sets this kart racer apart you
can create your own tracks and then
upload them for other people to try the
creativity doesn't stop there you can
also modify game rules create weapons
and more even though there's a pretty
steep learning curve to the editor
lastly littlebigplanet karting boasts
would mario kart 8 sort of left out
proper battle arenas you don't have
three little balloons floating over your
head but there are specially designed
ballerinas so you and your friends can
blow each other's heads off while it's
still being adorable
licensed games are usually just they
recreate whatever movie they're based on
in a crappy platformer or adventure game
for children so stay with me on this one
because cars to the game is actually
great a little bit Mario Kart a little
bit split second this isn't a story game
it's a racer along with the cart
mechanics and use of weapons you're
familiar with you have a jump button and
can perform flips spins and two wheel
driving tricks to fill up your boost bar
another trick throw your car in reverse
which can be used as a strategy to shoot
the cars behind you even though it is
cars themed with cars cutscenes and cars
voices the racing feels less skittish
instead of silly carts you have sleek
cars instead of banana peels and red
shells you have oil slicks on
side-mounted machine guns instead of
racing on high fantasy tracks you race
in locations like Tokyo London and
Monaco yes that Monaco track not to
mention some of the game modes are
straight from our FPS in hunter you
encounter waves of enemies in an arena
setting an attack you destroy as many
bodies as possible in limited time my
favorite multiplayer mode disruptor is
basically capture the flag but with cars
I'm sure you sped past this game at
Lightning McQueen speed but slow down
and get cars to a try because I promise
it is not just for kids which actually
shouldn't even matter because let's face
it we gamers are just big kids anyway of
course I always recommend the old
classics like crash team racing and
diddy kong racing but those are slightly
harder to get your hands on leave me a
comment with your favorite kart racer
and tweet me at lisa foiles and i'll see
you next week for another analog
[ __ ] you know who we are